all right so our first question is going
to come from kate from access hollywood
kate go for it
congratulations from one kate to um
another this evening
you have been such a trailblazer this i
mean your entire career but especially
with mayor of east town um i wonder as
you opened up and talked about a little
bit about your early years uh body
shaming and auditioning and being a
woman in the industry what does it mean
to stand here now for playing this role
of mayor what does it mean to you
it means a huge amount because it it
makes me feel genuinely that
that our industry is changing i i i am
re i'm honestly starting to feel that
that the shifts are happening and i
think that we're sort of we're
finger-pointing a lot less at women in
terms of how they look their shape you
know we stopped scrutinizing them and in
turn what happens then is that younger
generations of women who are not in our
industry
start to feel okay within themselves too
and that's more important than anything
else because it's up to us to be
absolutely being real and representing
ourselves with integrity and
authenticity
and celebrating each other and not
judging one another you know if we're
not doing that in our industry then
nobody else has got to hope in hell so i
feel like with playing mayor you know
maybe we are shifting the dynamics of
how leading ladies are seen on screen
and that just
it warms my heart makes me very very
happy
in your date night tonight with your
husband what has that been like i love
seeing you guys well i will tell you
that he's standing over there i will
tell you that when i was here 10 years
ago with mildred pierce i we had
actually just met
like we really had just met
and i
i and i knew that i was going to spend
my life with this with this man so i
came to the emmys and i was just so
in a whirlwind of having just met him
that i couldn't even concentrate and i
vividly remember making an absolutely
appalling speech because i was just not
on
on planet earth
because i had fallen head over heels in
love with this person who i just met so
to have him here it's really quite
really really quite special
beautiful story thank you so much for
sharing kate congratulations thank you
thank you kate uh next up from e news we
have ali rosenbloom go for it ali
hi congratulations thank you very much
i know that i speak for many many people
that i i could not get enough of season
one obviously what does this mean for a
possible season two
oh no you're not asking me that question
are you
um
i i honestly don't have a a clear answer
i mean there have been conversations
about it of course um because the
success of the show really did surprise
us all and that somehow you know it it
became this cultural moment this
zeitgeist moment that captured people's
attention um
in a really remarkable way so so yes the
conversations are happening but i think
until
i think until
scripts are in place that we can
really respond to and know what a full
story of a season two might be and also
where mayor goes you know because we'd
have to
we'd we'd no i think we'd we wouldn't be
able to match what we already did and
and nor should we try but we should do
our best to at least provide something
that is as captivating and entertaining
as season one um
so we'll see honestly we'll see i really
i truly don't know um what's going to
happen
thank you thank you thank you ali and
our final question is coming from lauren
zema from entertainment tonight go for
it lauren
kate so many congrats uh it was a pretty
amazing moment when evan took the stage
and he just yelled kate wins
i was wondering what went through your
mind and how happy are you that you and
jean and evan you you've had so many
wins tonight how will you all celebrate
well
i think we're probably gonna get drunk
um i i honestly i just feel i just feel
truly incredibly happy because
the the show was so hard it was so hard
for all of us and and we were absolutely
sort of united in trying to put this
thing together kovid cut right in the
middle going back to work was enormously
challenging and also quite frightening
you know um
and and we looked out for one another
and there was no hierarchy everyone was
treated exactly the same that was really
important to me and to the other
producers and and we really did create a
living breathing community that i i do
think comes through in the performances
and and in the sort of the rhythm and
the essence of the show and i feel very
proud of that that's who we were at work
and and i do think that you see it on
the screen and so i just feel so proud
of everyone and i'm so excited for for
all the crew this is going to mean i
can't tell you this is going to mean so
much to the crew they're going to be
absolutely freaking out um so it yeah i
mean i
i know i've been doing this job a really
long time but these moments they just
get more and more special and they mean
more all the time to me this this these
moments will never ever be wasted on
kate winslet i tell you
oh well
the show again so incredible please do a
season two and and please go get drunk
you deserve it um we did miss guy pierce
have you talked to guy he sent me a
message i saw a message pop up on my
phone so um so i'll probably be calling
him in the morning he's in europe um
yeah a wonderful guy pierce we share the
same birthday which is coming up on
october the 5th so we would join
together forever guy pierce and i'm very
very lucky to have him as a friend
happy early birthday definitely go get
drunk then thank you
[Music]
you